Billy Eilish just surprise some of her
biggest fans and you guys it is the
cutest thing you're gonna see all day yo
I'm Billy Eilish and I am here about to
surprise some fans we're gonna be
playing just a nice twenty20 that helps
something okay so here's what went down
some of Billy's fans showed up to test
out Just Dance 2020 which features
Billy's hit bad guy is that your
favorite song to sing it's funny because
I always see like the the Super Friends
gorilla I love to my core they're always
like like you know if you only know bad
guy like you're a fake fan and then
it'll all this stuff but I thought that
song I'm not bored of it at all I loved
it then there was this moment wait real
quick you might want to grab some
tissues I don't really have friends for
a long time and I would cry a lot felt
really bad about myself for a really
long time but then like literally the
cure to any bad moment I would just play
Billy Eilish and then I would just like
sing along and go back to my like weird
like quirky selfie I mean can you even
so little did these mega fans know Billy
was hiding out behind the curtain just
waiting to give them the surprise of
their lives so good right well it gets
even better just check out this girl who
was really going for it like going so
hard she didn't even realize Billy was
literally right there
[Music]
so what do you do when you meet your
idol um duh you dance duh but the fans
weren't the only ones on cloud nine
after the dance party Billie shared this
snippet from the video to her Instagram
writing this made me so happy
adding used to watch the one beaver did
years ago over and over and over
I can't believe my life you guys were so
sweet love you
yep Justin Bieber pulled the same stunt
back in 2012 I'm gonna go in and
surprise when did your love for the
Biebs start um you know what it started
when I was like 12 I believe and that
was like right before he retired where
did you post errors in your room I did
yeah like big ass next up for Billy
turning 18 okay you're gonna turn 18 in
December will you have a big birthday
party and what will this birthday party
look like ah um
I've been trying to think of it for
months okay
18 has been like the age I've always
wanted to be my entire life and where it
is yeah I have something in mind okay
but we'll get there I personally think
Billy should invite this girl to her
party
[Music]
she will tear up that dance floor I love
you
that was so unreal of course you can
count on et to bring you all the latest
Billy News so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]